nous aimerions commencer
par vous poser des
questions très stupides auxquelles vous avez probablement
dû répondre
maintes et maintes fois
première question que j'aimerais vous poser est-
ce que cela vous ennuie de promouvoir un de
vos films si le film est intéressant
assez pour en parler alors
ça vaut la peine de le faire pensez-vous que
les beautés parfaites
sont sexy euh
je suis un gars qui aime
moi-même la beauté imparfaite
mais je ne connais pas de très belles
beautés de belles femmes
qui sont parfaites je pense que si quelque chose est
parfait  alors c'est
euh j'aime la beauté imparfaite tu as
reçu beaucoup de lettres de
fans beaucoup de courrier de fans au fil des ans et
est-il difficile de
continuer à penser à agir quand tu as
toutes ces autres
ces autres distractions
euh c'est une question stupide
je ne pense pas que je n'ai jamais été cela n'a jamais
été autre chose que jouer pour moi
pense que n'importe qui peut  vous
apprendre à agir
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse vous apprendre à
agir je pense que c'est quelque chose que vous
apprenez par expérience
je ne vais pas qui est bob hughes
bien la première ligne que j'ai dans le film
je dis que j'étais une fois
un  fan de dope à temps plein sans vergogne et cela en
dit long sur les vues de bob il est fondamentalement une
sorte d'obsessionnel
je pense un peu compliqué mais ses
désirs sont très simples il est un toxicomane
et c'est tout ce qu'il vit vraiment
et respire pour
son prochain correctif  ses prochains médicaments où il
va avoir des
effets bien et je pense qu'en gros
c'est ce qu'il est en train de préparer pour le
cow-boy de la pharmacie vous avez fait beaucoup de
recherches avec vous parlez à des toxicomanes en
rétablissement
et à des gens avec qui vous êtes en quelque sorte très attaché au
personnage avez-vous fait
injecter de l'eau dans vos veines
j'ai fait beaucoup d'entre vous savez des choses pour le
film
que vous savez que j'estimais
nécessaires que vous savez pas forcément
ça n'a pas
fini sur le trône mais c'était bien pour
moi de faire ça comme
vous savez beaucoup de recherches que j'ai
faites pour le film, vous savez
parler à des toxicomanes et des trucs comme ça
alors je suis sorti et j'ai acheté
un ensemble d'œuvres dans la rue avec
ce toxicomane juste pour suivre la
routine mais je l'ai fait plus  comme une chose
que je voulais faire pour moi-même, ce n'était pas
quelque chose que quelqu'un m'avait demandé de faire
et nous l'avons fait dans une scène et
ce n'est même plus dans le film
parce que quand je l'ai vu,
j'ai un peu reculé  peu c'est
quelque chose d'étrange de se voir
s'injecter et crier alors mat dis moi que tu
as fait ce film tu as ce film
cowboy de la pharmacie tu l'as fait
tu as fait du bon travail je ne vais pas
discuter avec toi à ce sujet euh
mais comment tu t'es senti  pensez-vous que le
film allait être légèrement
controversé, pourquoi cela le rendrait-il
controversé? Je pense que
la raison pour laquelle il abandonne est ouais, il
s'épuise, vous savez, il finit par le rattraper
et je pense qu'il abandonne d'une certaine
manière  juste tu sais qu'il ne peut plus le faire
c'est juste  trop pour lui,
tu sais que la vie est usée euh
c'est controversé oui c'est je pense que
c'est légèrement controversé
mais nous avions l'impression que lorsque nous faisions le
film, le plus important était de le
rendre
réel, de le rendre honnête et si vous faites ça
tout  prendra soin de lui-même
afin que vous n'ayez pas à vous soucier de
prêcher à votre public ou de quoi que ce soit,
sauf pour le pot des désherbants et des
trucs comme ça avez-vous déjà
fait vous avez déjà pris de la drogue vous êtes-
vous mêlé de la drogue du tout mec
le  des trucs habituels que tu connais en grandissant je
veux dire que ce n'était pas tu sais que ça n'a jamais été un
problème je n'ai jamais
vraiment été un utilisateur mais tu sais le
genre habituel de
je déteste utiliser le mot expérimenter
parce que ça sonne toujours si faux
mais tu sais je '  je suppose une
sorte de récréation avec ça
mais jamais jamais ça n'a jamais été un problème je
n'en ai jamais utilisé autant
pensez-vous que le
cow-boy de la pharmacie du film va glamouriser la drogue de quelque façon
pensez-vous que ce sera de quelque façon
pensez-vous qu'il  aura le contraire
effet pensez-vous que c'est un film anti-
drogue ou
mat qu'en pensez-vous je ne
pense pas qu'il glorifie du
tout la toxicomanie
en fait je pense en fait euh
plutôt le contraire vous savez le gars qui a
écrit le livre est
sert comme s'il avait passé la
majeure partie de sa vie en prison à cause de son
implication dans la drogue,
je ne pense pas qu'il écrirait un livre
qui glorifierait la drogue, mais plus que cela,
je ne pense pas que le film le fasse, je pense que
c'est assez honnête pour  montrer que les gens
sont séduits dans la vie de prendre de la
drogue
et cela ne prétend pas que c'est
tout simplement une expérience misérable,
je pense que vous savez que c'est un peu honnête de
cette façon et montre que les gens l'apprécient réellement,
vous savez parce que je ne '  Je ne pense pas que vous pouvez
montrer
l'agonie et la douleur de prendre de la drogue
sans leur montrer le plaisir et
la séduction.
ça pourrait ma  ke sens
je ne prétends pas avoir toutes les réponses
tu sais
mais je pense hé écoute c'est une
forte possibilité que tu aies beaucoup moins de
crimes tu sais les crimes violents au moins en
amérique
quand tu as rencontré mademoiselle mitterrand je
comprends que vous deux  étaient très
tu avais pas mal de choses tu avais une
relation tu as juste assez
joué dans les médias vous deux avez
été vus ensemble
euh y a-t-il une vérité là-dedans je veux dire je
comprends que vous êtes
devenus assez proches passé
plusieurs soirées
juste  en quelque sorte vous êtes juste en train de vous balader en
ville
est-ce qu'il y a un fait dans ce
qu'il y a un fait dans le fait que
vous et mademoiselle Mitterrand
aviez un type de relation unique et spécial
avec qui elle était là
c'est ça nous jamais je pense que nous  peut-être
rencontré peut-être qu'on s'est serré la main et on ne s'est
jamais rencontré avant
bleu